it's a very interesting question as to
whether you can get a liberal education
outside the walls of academia there's no
question you can increasingly get the
core academic elements of that education
and I think that's a very powerful piece
of it but the Khan Academy whether it's
Coursera whether it's a DX or EDX these
are all purveyors of online education in
the case of Coursera and edex you're
providing the same courses in many cases
that you are you're able to do and I
think that the interaction the
interactive element will probably get
better and better
what you're not going to be able to
provide is the physical experience of
being together with people the lateral
learning the pure experience the
socialization think about our all our
lives we all know that people who
succeed in life often have very good
social skills have very good political
skills they understand how to read a
room read somebody else sell to someone
so those qualities might not be as well
as well taught in an entirely online
experience but I think again the point
is that the pricing power of a college
will be under significant strain if
somebody says look I wasn't able to
afford to go to college X but I have
taken 32 courses which are the number of
colleges courses you need to graduate
from that college and they're from
college X but also from Harvard Stanford
Yale and I did pretty well in them and
here are my diplomas my certificates
that I've completed those 32 college
courses will you hire me and when an
employer says we'll hire you because you
have the training you need for this job
or you have the background you need for
this job there goes the pricing model
from many colleges not the elite
colleges the the very elite colleges are
selling membership to a private club but
for mostly everybody else you will have
to explain why you're charging forty
thousand dollars a year
you